Miley Cyrus and Liam Hemsworth have
officially called it quits the 26 year
old singers rep confirmed to et that she
and her beau have split after seven
months of marriage now we're taking a
look back at their epic on-again
off-again relationship
this made me feel like you do right
Miley and Liam were just babies when
they met back in 2009 on the set of the
last song we're always together and I
never get I'd never get bored of them
because we always have stuff to talk
about and even if we don't it's fun just
being into this company so you phased by
March 2010 they'd made their
relationship official with a red carpet
debut now there are rumors that you were
involved with Miley during the filming
of last song is this true yes only for
them to call it off for the first time
in August in April 2011 Miley and Liam
reunited and by March 2012 engagement
rumors were swirling which Miley was
quick to squash tweeting I'm not engaged
I've worn this same ring on this finger
since November fast forward to June when
they confirmed that they actually were
engaged turns out Liam popped the
question in May I really don't think
there's anyone hotter that's like making
films as him but by March 2013 the rumor
mill was already talking about split
number two Miley initially put rumors to
bed tweeting I'm so sick of La and sick
of all the lies that come with it I
didn't call off my wedding taking a
break from social media hashtag draining
but we learned in April of that year
that the wedding was reportedly
postponed and by September they
officially announced that their
engagement was off the next day Liam was
photographed kissing actress a second's
allas meanwhile Miley went on to have
several relationships a brief but very
public fling with patrick Schwarzenegger
in November 2014
she was also linked to Victoria's Secret
models tell
Maxwell in July 2015 in August 2015
Miley came out as pin sexual and single
[Music]
but you'll never believe who was back in
Miley's life by that November after she
helped him find the perfect dog to adopt
by January 2016 she was rocking her
engagement ring once again and in
October the couple confirmed they were
back on
Miley and Liam faced tragedy in November
2018 when they lost their Malibu home to
the Wolsey fire I feel so lucky to be
with someone like her very very very
lucky and in December they surprised the
world by tying the knot in an intimate
ceremony it's me my wife that's great
tobe wife husband and wife it's the best
it's the best
Miley graced the cover of Elle magazine
in August where she revealed that
despite being married she's still very
sexually attracted to women
[Music]
cut to Friday when the singer was
photographed making out with Brody
Jenner's ex Caitlyn Carter while on
vacation in Lake Como Italy just one day
before news broke that she and Liam had
called it quits
[Music]